[Music]
there's been a parade of leaders through
Beijing in recent weeks
but few have been met with a welcome
like this
[Music]
heiner rolled out the red carpet for
president macron both literally and
metaphorically
[Music]
but for all the show there's still more
than just a language barrier between
these two leaders merci beaucoup
at the negotiating table there was much
to discuss a war in Ukraine and China's
position on it
the Russian aggression in Ukraine has
dealt a blow to this stability and put
an end to Decades of Peace in Europe and
I know that I can count on you to bring
Russia to reason and everyone to the
negotiating table
China claims it's neutral in the war a
potential broker of Peace but these
scenes in Moscow last month indicate
otherwise
even here aside macron she made it clear
Russia's interests shouldn't be
forgotten
take into account the legitimate
security concerns of all parties seek
political resolutions and build a
balanced effective and sustainable
European security framework
this Mission clearly matters the EU
commission boss is here too to push it
the real fear is what happens if China
goes further and sells arms to Russia
arming the aggressor is a clear
violation of international law it's the
aggressor and he should never be armed
and this would indeed significantly harm
the relationship between the European
Union and China a threat made more
stinging by being delivered on Chinese
soil but will it land
a relationship with Europe has value for
China not just economically but also as
a buffer against its plummeting
relations with America but it also has
lots of reasons why it doesn't want to
see Russia weakened and defeated it's
therefore very possible the visits like
this won't make much difference
indeed China's number one goal is to
protect the interests of China for now
it's careful Balancing Act is most
likely to remain Helena Smith Sky News
in Beijing